قبل يومين اذا من السباق الرئاسي التركي
الذي سيحسم سيحسم طبعا بالجوله الثانيه
الاتراك ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر يوم الاحد
المقبل لمعرفه من سيحكم البلاد الرئيس
التركي اردوغان ام مجددا طبعا اردوغان
مجددا ام كمال
مرشح المعارضه ولكن ما هي اليه الجوله
الثانيه وهل تختلف عن الجوله الاولى من
الناحيه التقنيه لا يوجد فرق الا
ان الفرق الوحيد طبعا بالجوله الثانيه انه
لا يشترط حصول المرشح على خمسين زائد واحد
كما في الجوله الاولى والذي ينال اصواتا
اكثر يكسب السباق الرئاسي حتى ولو بفارق
صوت واحد فقط صناديق الاقتراع مشاهدينا
ستفتح وتفتح يوم الاحد عند الساعه الثامنه
صباحا وستغلق عند الساعه الخامسه مساء
ليبدا اعلان النتائج بشكل تدريجي كما في
الجوله الاولى اللافت ايضا في الجوله
الثانيه بان 47 الف شاب وشاب اكمل اسامي
عشره من عمرهم بعد الجوله الاولى التي
كانوا فيها قاصرين وبالتالي حماست هؤلاء
لتصويت للمره الاولى ستدفعهم للاقتراع
ولكن من غير المعروف اين ستصب اصوات
الشباب التركي هنا ايضا يجب التوقف عند
الناخبين الذين لم يصوتوا في الجوله
الاولى وعدد هؤلاء ثمانيه ملايين حيث يعمل
كل من اردوغان وكلستار اوغلو للاستماله
اصواتهم لان كل صوت سيكون مؤثر لحسم
السباق في الجوله جوله الاعاده الثانيه في
الجوله الثانيه ايضا مشاهدينا كان لاصوات
المغتربين صدى اكبر من الاولى وبحسب
الارقام الاخيره فقد صوت اكثر من مئه الف
ناخب جديد عن الرقم الماضي بجولات الاعاده
الاكراد والخشيه من فوز اردوغان وسط تصاعد
النبره القوميه قبيل جوله الاعاده
الانتخابات التركيه واحتماليه فوز اردوغان
الذي اثار قلقا في صفوف الاكراد خوفا من
تصعيد عسكري الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد
تؤكد دعمها للمعارضه التركيه لكنهم لم
يذكروا بالاسم
النظام الغريب الذي اسسه اردوغان وشركائه
سبب المشاكل المجتمعيه التي نعاني منها ما
سيتم تصويت عليه في 28 من مايو هو مدى
امكانيه استمرار هذا النظام الغريب من
عدمه
تحول في المواقف في سنواته الاولى من
السلطه منح اردوغان المزيد من الحقوق
للاكراد والغى القيود المفروضه على
استخدام اللغه الكرديه عام 2015 وبعد
انهيار وقف اطلاق النار غير اردوغان مساره
السياسي
وشنت السلطات التركيه حمله قمع ادت الى
اعتقال الالاف من الاكراد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات